>>> TONIGHT, WHAT THE HELL IS
GOING ON?
THAT'S THE QUESTION FROM
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IN
CALIFORNIA.
EIGHT LIVES LOST AFTER A GUNMAN
OPENS FIRE.
THE GUNMAN IS AN EMPLOYEE AT
THAT RAIL YARD.
ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS AT THE
SAME TIME THE SHOOTING WERE
UNFOLDING, OFFICIALS WERE CALLED
TO A FIRE AT THE GUNMAN'S HOME.
INVESTIGATORS ARE TRYING TO
DETERMINE IF THE GUNMAN WHO TOOK
HIS OWN LIFE WAS TRYING TO DO
MUCH WORSE THAN THE DEVASTATION
HE ALREADY PULLED OFF.
AS WE SPEAK, TEAMS ARE GOING
ROOM TO ROOM IN THAT FACILITY
NOW SEARCHING FOR EXPLOSIVES.
THE EIGHT PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES JOINED BY 7500 PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DIED FROM GUN VIOLENCE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, JUST THIS
YEAR.
>> THAT'S A 23% UP-TICK IN DEATH
FROM LAST YEAR.
THIS ATTACK AS TO THE VERY CLEAR
MASS SHOOTING IN THE UNITED
STATES.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR TODAY SAYS
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> IT BEGS THE QUESTION OF WHAT
THE HELL IS GOING ON IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH US?
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ORDERING
FLAGS TO BE LOWERED HALF STAFF.
SAYING THE FOLLOWING, "ENOUGH,
ONCE AGAIN I URGE CONGRESS TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION AND HEED
THE CALL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
INCLUDING THE VAST MAJORITY OF
GUN OWNERS TO HELP END THIS
EPIDEMIC OF GUN.
WE CAN AND WE MUST DO MORE."
>> JOSH CAMPBELL IS "OUTFRONT"
IN SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA, WITH
THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: AN EARLY MORNING
MASSACRE.
>> WE HAVE EIGHT VICTIMS FROM
TODAY'S INCIDENT FROM GUNSHOT
WOUNDS.
WE HAVE ONE SUSPECT WHO'S
DECEASED AS WELL.
>> Reporter: SHOTS RANG OUT
AROUND 6:30 A.M. AT THIS SAN
JOSE MAINTENANCE YARD WHERE
COMMUNITY RAIL VEHICLES WERE
BEING DISPATCHED.
THE LONE SUSPECT IDENTIFIED AS
SANG CASSIDY.
>> IT IS CLEAR THAT THE VICKS
AND ALL THE COLLEAGUES THERE
KNEW THE SHOOTER WELL.
>> Reporter: CASSIDY CONTINUED
TO SHOOT EVERYONE AS POLICE
ARRIVE.
>> I KNEW WHEN THE SUSPECT KNEW
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS THERE,
HE TOOK HIS OWN LIFE.
OUR DEPUTIES WERE RIGHT THERE AT
THAT TIME.
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE SAYS MORE
DEADLY PLANS WERE LAID OUT IN
ADVANCE.
>> WE RECEIVED INFORMATION THAT
THERE ARE EXPLOSIVE DEVICES THAT
ARE LOCATED INSIDE THE BUILDING.
>> MULTIPLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE BOMB
SQUAD ARE ON THE SCENE,
BEGINNING WHAT IS LIKELY TO BE A
LENGTHY AND EXTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION.
>> WE ARE SO SORRY THIS EVENT
HAPPENED.
WE ARE THERE FOR YOU.
PEOPLE IN THE ORGANIZATION KNOW
EVERYONE.
THIS IS A TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
>> Reporter: A NEIGHBOR TOOK
THIS VIDEO OF THE SUSPECT'S HOME
BELLOWING WITH SMOKE AND A
SUSPICIOUS BLAZE.
FIREFIGHTERS RESPONDED TO THE
SCENE AT 6:36 A.M., TWO-MINUTES
AFTER THE FIRST CALL FROM THE
SHOOTING AT THE RAIL YARD CAME
IN.
INVESTIGATORS ARE NOW ON-SITE AT
BOTH LOCATIONS SEARCHING FOR
ANSWERS.
WHILE CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNOR HAS
MORE QUESTIONS OF HIS OWN.
>> WHAT THE HE HELL'S GOING ON
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
WHAT THE HELL IS GONGING ON WIT
US.
>> Reporter: SIX OF THE EIGHT
VICTIMS KILLED, THEIR BODIES ARE
STILL BEHIND ME HERE AND STILL
BEING PROCESSED BY CORONERS.
WE UNDERSTAND SPECIAL AGENTS AND
THE FBI ARE AT THE SHOOTER'S
HOUSE RIGHT NOW PROCESSING THAT
SCENE AND TRYING TO GET ANY
EVIDENCE THEY CAN TO TRY TO GET
TO THE MOTIVE OF THE LATEST MASS
SHOOTING IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> JOSH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> A COUNCIL MEMBER IN SAN JOSE,
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE LAST TIME WE HEARD FROM YOU
WAS DURING A PRESS CONFERENCE,
YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT YOU WERE
WAITING TO HEAR FROM YOUR
CHILDHOOD FRIEND.
SOMEONE WHO WORKS AT THIS VERY
RAIL YARD.
THE MAYOR TONIGHT SAID VERY
SADLY THAT YOUR FRIEND WAS
KILLED TODAY.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING?
>> WE DON'T HAVE FINAL
CONFIRMATION ON THAT.
WE ARE WAITING FOR THAT.
I HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE
FAMILY.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT IT LOOKS
LIKE OF ALL THE SHOOTING VI
VICTIMS, THERE IS ONLY ONE
THAT'S IN CRITICAL CONDITION IN
THE HOSPITAL, THEY'RE NOT
TELLING ANY OF THE FAMILIES OF
THE VICTIMS OR THE IDENTITIES OF
THOSE WHO ARE DECEASED.
IT DOES NOT LOOK GOOD.
I KNOW OBVIOUSLY ALL THE
FAMILIES THERE ARE TRYING TO
REMAIN HOPEFUL BUT IT IS A VERY
CHALLENGING TIME AS WE ARE SORT
OF WAITING FOR THAT UNFORTUNATE
NEWS.
>> EVERYONE IS STILL WAITING.
WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT WAITING
LIKE THIS IS LIKE.
I TRULY, I CAN'T -- THIS IS VERY
PERSONAL FOR YOU.
WHAT DOES THIS WAIT FEEL LIKE?
>> IT IS FRUSTRATING.
I HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH HIS
FAMILY THAT ARE THERE.
I CAN TELL YOU THEY ARE
FRUS
FRUSTRATED AS WELL.
YOU CAN IMAGINE RIGHT NOW IT IS
WANTING TO KNOW AND ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT INFORMATION, CLEARLY
EVERYONE WANTS TO HOLD ON HOPE.
EVERY MINUTE THAT GOES BY IT
BECOMES MORE CHALLENGING TO DO
SO.
FOR ME IT HAS BEEN AGONIZING ALL
AROUND AND BEING A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THIS AREA AND
BEING A BOARD MEMBER AND
PERSONALLY HAVING A LONG TIME
FA
FAMILY FRIEND HAS BEEN TOUGH.
>> I AM SO SORRY, I AM REALLY
AM.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT EIGHT MORE
FAMILIES THAT ARE SHATTERED AND
TA DON'T KNOW IT YET BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN TOLD.
THIS IS THE 16 MASS SHOOTINGS
SINCE FRIDAY IN AMERICA: YOU
JUST HEARD WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAD
SAID EARLIER TODAY AND HE WAS
EXACERBATED AND SAID "WHAT THE
HELL IS GOING ON IN AMERICA,
WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH US?"
>> CONGRESSMAN, WHAT THE HE
WOW HELL
IS WRONG WITH US?
>> I WISH WE CAN STOP THIS.
IF IT WAS SO SIMPLE, WE WOULD
HAVE DONE IT ALREADY.
THESE DEBATES ARE HOTLY
CONTESTED ON WHAT THE ISSUES ARE
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT GUN
CONTROL OR THIS INCIDENT THAT
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
THE REALITY HERE IN THIS CASE,
WE ARE GOING TO DISSECT THAT AND
TRYING TO GET DOWN TO WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT JUST YET.
WE DO KNOW THAT FOR NUMEROUS
OTHER MASS SHOOTINGS AND ACTIVE
SHOOTERS THAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY AT SCHOOLS AND MOVIE
THEATERS AND MALLS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
NOT BE HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT THE GOVERNOR WAS
EXPRESSING HIS FRUSTRATION THAT
I SHARE AS WELL.
>> YOU GREW UP A LONG LIFE
RESIDENT OF SAN JOSE.
SAN JOSE IS NOW JOINING THE LONG
LIST OF CITIES IN AMERICA WHERE
A MASS SHOOTING JUST TAKEN
PLACE.